[Music]
Vsauce Kevin here headed to the control
room of the USS Pasadena a Los Angeles
class nuclear-powered fast attack
submarine the Pasadena is over 100
metres long has a crew of nearly 130 and
is propelled by a thermal Neutron
reactor that generates 35,000 shaft
horsepower and it has a lot of buttons
so I'm gonna press this one hey don't
touch that or anything right
I'm here with petty officer John Davis
machinists mate
nuclear first class and trained Rescue
Diver with the United States Navy I'm
100 meters deep in the Pacific Ocean
with an expert in thermodynamics nuclear
reactor technology fluid dynamics
mathematics and more we're gonna tap
that knowledge to get to the bottom of a
game that's been a staple of kitchen
tables for a century
battleship battleship evolved from my
pencil and paper a French game called an
attack which eventually became Stratego
by the 1960s Milton Bradley developed
the classic 10 by 10 grid in which each
player places five ships a carrier that
occupies five spaces a battleship on
four and a cruiser and submarines that
are each on three a destroyer on two
ships can't overlap but they can touch
the actual gameplay is really simple the
first player guesses a location on the
grid say c4 and the second player says
whether that shot hit one of their ships
or missed entirely if it's a Miss then
we both mark our grids with a white peg
if it's a hit then we'll mark it with a
red one the object is to hit each
location on all five ships and sync them
and it seems like there's really no
perfect way to start we've got 100
possibilities and all of them equally
valid with seventeen possible hits our
first random shot is going to hit about
one in five times so I'll start f7 miss
random guesses in battleship are just a
massive exercise in probability and a
simulation by Nick berry of data
genetics Joe died using this random
system means over 99% of games will
require at least seventy eight shots be
seven miss playing totally randomly
would be really really inefficient and
unless both players are choosing all
shots randomly you'd lose almost every
time and real randomness is actually
pretty pretty hard research as early as
the 1930s showed that humans aren't
capable of generating a random number
sequence and modern research and
economics shows that decision making is
incredibly difficult when we have to try
to make sense of randomness a three miss
computers are a lot better at handling
randomness but pure randomness just is
an optimal here the way most people play
battleship is a blend
first make sure randomly until they get
a hit and then they go up down left and
right around that hit to find the next
part of the ship d5 hit
that's what Barry calls the hunt end
target method you start by randomly
firing shots and then work around your
hits to sink ships by repeating that
strategy the average game will take
about 65 shots
that's better than random but it's not
great h8 miss the next level strategy is
what's called parody where you recognize
that the board of a hundred spaces is
actually no more than fifty because the
smallest ship has off by at least two
spaces we can think of the battleship
board like a checkerboard of alternating
colors we can hunt on just one color and
then target when we get a hit
d six hit and sunk
battleships smallest unit is two so once
the destroyer has been sunk like you
just did then that expands to three then
four and five hunt and target with
parody improves our average number of
moves nearer to sixty so it's a little
better but still not optimal be to miss
we can employ a rough algorithm in our
minds that takes into account both the
board and whether ships of a certain
link are likely to be a certain position
on that board g9 miss a computer can do
this perfectly judging the probability
of given ships lengths being placed in
the leftover spaces on the board this
will change with every single move and
will create a sort of heat map and
suggest where we should guess next I'm
gonna guess next d4 hit you'll start the
game with no information at all so the
best option is to shoot here the center
and adjust from there
guess recalibrate repeat each time
refining your probability based on the
layout of spaces left and a length of
the ships you haven't sunk a nine hit we
can't do this as fast or as perfectly as
a computer but we can generate a pretty
good approximation in our minds as we
play each game of battleship were
employing a probability density function
and refining an algorithm in our brains
with every move statistically there's a
massive payoff to this approach it drops
the number of shots required into the
30s or 40s with very finding that all
100,000,000 games he simulated were
completed by about 65 moves
c4 hit that's how so much of practical
math science and engineering works we
make an approximation and then hone in
on the details the best we can
considering all the variables unknowns
and randomness and then put it together
with constant adjustments to make
something complex function flawlessly
b9
hit it's a constant process but whether
you're optimizing the probability behind
a 50-year old board game or navigating
one of the most advanced naval vessels
ever created today we have an
opportunity to learn refine and evolve
faster than ever before
wait did you say b4 yeah and you sunk my
submarine worried not not this submarine
no and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
to check out more videos like this go to
sailor versus comm die Sarah Sarah okay
and it's got a lot of buttons so I'm
gonna touch this one sorry nuclear such
an idiot okay yeah you like it I like it
[Music]